Madrid is a city divided split by a
deep-rooted passion and rivalry the
self-proclaimed kings of Europe Real
Madrid a team hungry to bring their 11th
european cup home to the santiago
bernabéu stadium their diehard
supporters are quietly confident but
also concerned that their neighbors may
cause an upset I would have preferred a
different rival barn Munich or any other
team because they're our neighbors if
they win they'll be reminding us of it
over and over again it's completely
normal for a Madrid to win we just take
it in our stride after losing the 2014
champions league final to real madrid
crosstown rivals Atletico are still in
search of their first European Cup they
call tornadoes as Atleti fans call
themselves are known for their
unwavering support even through the bad
times it's pure emotion it's not about
gold we feel our passion in our heart we
feel atleti's strength and gutsy
attitude each club has a focal point for
their celebrations in the Spanish
capital the Greek goddess DeBellis for
Madridistas and neb dunno Fred let ego
Madrid supporters but what's the history
behind it in the lower than italic film
for a second Center in the nineteen
eighty six World Cup supporters of
Spain's national team converged on
favelas after a big win Emilio
Butragueno was part of the team I'm one
of ram Madrid's icons so after that real
madrid supporters spontaneously began to
go to the-- Bellus to celebrate their
big victories a few years later atlético
won the Spanish Cup and considering Real
Madrid were already using favelas they
decided to go to Neptune if we are the
only certainty is that the Champions
League trophy and not this replica will
call Madrid home for the next year
whatever the outcome madrileños are
proud that one of their great teams
whether it be real madrid or Atletico
Madrid will be crowned the best club in
Europe this season